a drug used in medication abortions the
most common method to end a pregnancy is
at the center of the latest legal battle
over abortion access federal judges in
Texas and Washington issued decisions
that appear directly at odds with one
another one suspends approval of the
drug mifiprestone by the Food and Drug
Administration the other prevents the
FDA from restricting access to the drug
in some states Laura casisto is a
national legal Affairs reporter and
leads abortion coverage for the journal
she explains what the decisions mean and
what comes next
a Texas judge said that the FDA had
improperly approved a drug know the one
as miffapristone he suspended that
approval saying the FDA hadn't
adequately considered the safety of the
drug they'd use the wrong procedure for
approving the drug the FDA had approved
the drug under a pathway that's used to
approve drugs to treat life-threatening
illnesses and the judge said most of us
would not understand pregnancy to be a
serious life-threatening illness he also
said that the FDA had not adequately
taken to an account possible concerns
about Hemorrhage about infection about
mental trauma that women could suffer so
this ruling is really significant
because it affects abortion access not
just in Texas but around the country if
the judge's ruling does go into effect
that would mean that the pill could be
pulled from the market and so this is
really kind of one of the first
developments we've seen that has
potential Nationwide significance since
Roe v Wade was overturned it's
completely out of bound what the judge
did journalists and lawyers were all
still digesting this really kind of
Blockbuster role going out of Texas we
got this other really quite unexpected
ruling from a judge in Washington state
it appears the judge there is saying
that the FDA can't take additional
action at the moment to further
constrain access to the abortion pill
now that really only applies in states
that were parties in the lawsuit but in
those States there's like a real tension
between the rulings of these two judges
there's a concern that this could really
destabilize the drug approval process in
general if you have judges potentially
second guessing the FDA what I will say
is a caveat to that is that you know
this is abortion this is not a typical
drug an uncontroversial drug this is
something that has been at the center of
a political firestorm in this country
for five decades it's not a perfect
analogy for other drugs it is contrary
to what makes for good Public Health
policy to allow courts and politicians
to tell the FDA what it should do
the by Administration moved quickly to
appeal the ruling they filed something
with the fifth circuit the court of
appeals asking for them to stay the
ruling and they've asked for them to
make a decision by Thursday that could
go one of two ways they can give the
Biden Administration what they want so
they can put this ruling on hold or they
can not they can allow it to go into
effect and then in that instance I think
you're very likely going to see the
Biden Administration turn around very
quickly and file an appeal with the
Supreme Court We Stand by the fda's
approval of mifa Preston and we are
prepared for a long legal fight
foreign
[Music]